hey welcome to our we're gonna be
talking about it's gone in 60 seconds
thing yeah we're gonna be talking about
the honest trailer for one of those
fifty shades movies you know the one do
you know the one it's freed yeah freed
yeah yeah sure so watch that video come
back watch this video get some
behind-the-scenes insight into our
process and and stick around I think
there's some deleted scenes at the end
I'm Spencer Shay Gilbert that's Joe
Stark
that's Dan tomorrow hello drop the
confetti we're done guys what a long
strange trip it's been
I never thought I would see all of these
movies more than once but this job makes
strange bedfellows so to speak yeah here
we are
yeah some days you get jaws and
sometimes you get this yep
garbage oh these are terrible films
poorly cast written poorly directed yeah
poorly structured poorly made now the
thing is received and I would like to
echo all of that while also maintaining
and adding that it's not that I don't
like films that are made for a female
audience in mind or films that are or
eroticism or things that are like
boundary-pushing supposedly in that
sense this was just a bad execution all
around of all of these things well the
source material was a bad execution it
was a bad execution of a poorly executed
thing to begin with it's like bad I'm
bad I'm bad I'm bad you had a director
in the first one she tried and
retrospect the best one retrospect the
best one she did her best she did her
best to try to elevate it above the
source material at the Elgin same with
Dakota Johnson yes she did her best she
did her best
al Johnson l james looked at the first
one it was just like no don't do that
and didn't like that they were trying to
elevate it so then the last two and
bringing in outside help from inside by
Mary to write them and
yeah you know it's it's it's not even a
case of like what more could you do they
could have done much much more and in
the case of the sequel's chose to not do
that yeah it is with the cast it starts
we're trying we're trying our best we
know this isn't great and then the
second one they're just resigned and
just very like they should have recast
it with fans yeah I think if they had
fantana's character after from for the
second and third movie every couple of
scenes it switches to a new fan no I
think they like it was you know you'd
have a golden ticket inside the books so
you know some no shame yeah in this
movie this movie in particular or where
does it depart from the other two it's
pretty much the same thing right no it's
very plot II yeah it tries out if the
second one was really plot e2 though
yeah but it was still kind of had that
tinge of just like it's about like the
first it was like it's about to sex and
then the second was like it's about the
sex and the plot and then this one is
like it's about the plot and there's
also some sex but it's really about this
very serious plot yes about God my wife
stolen it turned into like a like a spy
thriller randomly or graduate so
gradually we definitely notice that it
becomes like Christian Grey I think they
wanted to make like a James Bond movie
out of this cold-hearted sex murder or
is this a Bond movie with just all the
cool Bond stuff taken out except for the
sexy parts well no I mean he's got some
cool stuff he's got a how the nice house
and the Jets
and of plane we're just skipping the
parts where he like goes to work and
like punches spies yeah yeah this is no
meeting with him in him no he's the bad
guy which is again something we cut from
this is he's the bad guy in the Bond
movie he's the guy that James Bond would
be like his named herb Q M or would be
like it's a it's his name's Christian
Grey posing as a wealthy philanthropist
who has work and telecommunications or
god knows what
it's something in Africa he's secretly
you know going to suck all the plankton
out of the world's oceans and then James
Bond would seduce Anastasia Anastasia
yeah except your name would be like post
walnut clamp or the swap nip clamp yes
she'd turned the tables on him and he'd
wake up you know this is a much better
movie than what we got yeah I think
there's a lot of potential for
crossovers with this couple and other
films with James Bond with Batman we
were saying earlier with the mask with
Jackson there's a lot of potential
moving on and adding some spice into
this so yeah all right let's watch our
dumb trailer for it and wait and give it
the send-off it deserves
so far the send-off it deserves yeah
[Music]
it started with a bang then in the
sequel your aunt Bev spank bank started
to run dry you want to vanilla
relationship now in the final chapter
huh final sure now the final chapter
lands with all the sex appeal of day old
lunch meat left out in the rain Fifty
Shades freed
delete mr. and mrs. gray two people
definitely rushed into marriage
you own this you do want to have kids
someday right would you change your name
for me these are things you gotta go
back to that there's a scene in this
movie where he randomly and nowhere else
in this movie go to that shot of him in
the office has a beard for no reason
comments on the beard and says you need
to shave now what what what happened
it's a riot so it's a Rishi is it a
reshoot well this is a very important
scene to pick ups yeah I really wish
that they had Superman's mustache this
given him somewhat of a baby bottom of
the face I showed up at your work in the
middle of a meeting because I'm not the
Conan O'Brien bit yeah yeah I learned
healthfully possessive of you talk about
this yeah I do the whatever that's
called just the snapchat face SWAT with
himself that is what happen in this
franchise continuity yeah the beards for
no reason and then she'll say go shave
the beard and he does off-screen for no
reason when things happen off-screen in
the series remember he used to have like
his mistress who like trained him in the
dominating arts it was yes some famous
basically basically obviously declined
to return a my god she's like I had died
off-screen planet she was like honey
horn a deserves
thanks Duke Bond girls all right let's
keep going right along with main
characters who are clearly the villains
of their own movie as the stuck of
billionaires it's gonna they're insecure
sharing your thorough fraud with a squad
of armed goons he'll be in charge of
your personal security and a secret room
full of restraints and torture devices
run a shadowy corporation whose business
is never really explained I love what
you're doing enough okay
oh thank you ten bucks says it's a moon
laser that runs on blood diamonds cause
I another day this is yeah he's a
classic movie CEO because he's never
working he's only doing fun stuff like
only the aughts only the sex dungeon jet
ski the big house remodeling yes like
that
this guy is never like hold on oh I
gotta take this Anna and I get it I get
it
I know you want the ice cream on the
balls I got I got it I have to take this
call never too busy the only time you've
seen him at work is when he is ignoring
what's happening at work to live text
Anna like yeah there are you or leave
work in this world he was a guest on
shark tank at any point yeah a guest
shark a shark we're supposed to have a
meeting with Christian Grey today and
just hard cut to him on a jet ski with
his girlfriend yeah yeah Wow
we don't even know what he does I can't
even imagine what he pitched like yes
holding moon lasers and the scrub daddy
yeah yeah that's where kids the scrub
daddy Empire the Chinese finger trap for
your entire face I call it a face
let's keep watch Jamie Dornan and Dakota
Johnson crackle with all the intensity
of siblings is it to the point now with
you and Dakota Johnson where it's like
this is go
so bad but it's almost like brother
sister as his Christian last night that
you were dead
while her Anastasia Steele glutes and
squeaks like a sex doll cursed with live
and pus do you think that those were
that was a deliberate choice or was she
just stopping herself from laughing and
that's certainly what the critic
screening sounded like for this movie
yeah didn't it finally break after after
a certain point like the flat shaded
shades darker where it out broke open
right
this one it was pretty much derision
from the start there was all sense of
propriety was gone yeah this makes me
want to I always forget but we got to
fire up the riff tracks for this one I
feel like the RiffTrax B I bet they'd be
pretty perfect yes yeah this is the kind
of movie that was made to be it was made
to be riff - I have sadly not listened
to a new one in quite so yeah and I need
to not since the happening I think yeah
anyway so check those guys out I missed
e3k and let's continue with our parody
is there dynamic remains exactly the
same as you remember it guy
psychologically batters girl because you
would stepped out I think it Dana and I
were just going over notes and just like
ridiculous things and I and I was like
why of all the couches to go to why
would you go to the one in the sex
dungeon don't sleep on that couch and
then Dan was like why would you sleep on
the couch when there's a bed right next
literally two feet away from that couch
is an unused bed and she cuddles up on
that house what's happening on that bed
I can't be worse than what's happened on
that couch for that patent-leather it's
got grooves in it it's got those buttons
in it like those deep indentations yeah
you're right cuz they probably burn the
sheets yeah I'm sure they do
yes where she's just crunched into this
couch with like a fireman blanket like
give you if your condo burned down
sadly because he's like such a
a abusive boyfriend or husband it's
probably just because that room locks
from the inside she can like she locked
him out yeah she can like put a you know
like a clamp across the door doubles as
a panic room he's very thrifty
exactly yeah yeah yeah there's a bed
literally two feet away from that couch
the poor servants that have to hose that
thing down agador spartacus or whatever
rest just they probably just thought
yeah girl you insist on defying me girl
puts up token defiance let me drive it
no let me drive that guy plows through
it it makes up for abuse with the
vehicle ride you can't just buy your way
out of everything Christian some things
don't have a price like friendship never
mind
Webster's what happened to team Jacob
the other guy in the trio I'd forgotten
about it remember he has a whole art
exhibit Woods just stock photos of
Dakota Johnson yeah so I'm stocked her
and took pictures of her yeah Christian
what is creepier from the second movie
the fact that he against her will put
photos of her in an art show or that
Christian gray bought all of them so
that no one else could look at her
except for him except for her while they
weren't even a couple they weren't
together yeah I have also watched bail
three just as many times as you guys and
I forgot all of these people existed I
did too I couldn't when we were watching
this one I could not remember who any of
if they had been in the big and I was
like not Beth no that's that's Rita Ora
yeah stop trying to make readers see the
real estate person I could have these
characters are so in this age I could
not remember who they were yeah they all
kind of melted melted away into the
background of the romance
yeah Team Jacob though got the heave-ho
he barely aligned yeah poor guy same
with the actual team Jacob what happened
to Taylor Lautner let's go say Taylor
Kitsch and Taylor Lautner the Taylors
Taylor Kitsch got way fewer chances off
of way better movies and
yeah I don't know he was in that Adam
Sandler Achilles six like an action
movie where he became like a badass oh
yeah he was in this group the steel that
steel but it was like steel really it
was a robot suit movie that made like
0dl steel yeah no not that okay oh it's
like it's like a cartoon adaptation he
was like a born thing I don't know well
you respond in the comments below what
movies do any Fifty Shades for 25
million dollars from Twilight that's
true I promise you he's fine yeah he's
doing good I mean if he wants to work he
should be able to but you know pick your
pick your projects in summary we wish
you well
it takes a player to find sexual
intercourse as intercourse involving
penetration of the vagina by the penis
and by definition this is a very sexy
movie Sean as the bondage elements stay
as tame as ever
while they upped the ante by having
regular sex where you'd never want to
like during a haircut what on the
parking brake with dairy products oh and
where everyone else because that's
Dario's with a light mr. Diaz and a
sweat dude clearly so close is a nasty
trilogy designed to separate your
seventh-grade young soldier from a
paycheck that masquerades as a story
about empowering women and sexual
freedom even though the heroine marries
the first guy she has sex with gets her
dream job because he bought the company
spends most of her free time hogtied and
after spending a movie fighting against
being barefoot and pregnant pregnant
ends the trilogy literally barefoot and
pregnant and it's gonna be awkward when
those kids dumb one to mom and dad's
King dungeon I know it was for me yes
another layer of the onion especially
throughout these films you've gotten
peeks into the epic voice guy not John
Bailey but the epic voice guy that life
of his boring marriage his desire to
spice it up childhood
yeah yeah was he an orphan adopted by a
different family than another orphan who
would come that way revenge on him so I
AG epic voice guy always comes and
argues with them because he's a jack of
the yellow challenge Oh God
we'll settle this in a video no one will
watch exactly and this is something that
the movie itself ended with it's just
like let's just end with a clip show you
guys have sat through this long enough
so if we so we did the same of just
picking some of our choicest clips yeah
that really sum up the whole franchise
experience this flashback of the dumbest
moments in the franchise laters baby
can't wait to never see you again
I used to write I lost a bit on my
blackberry you wrote it on your
blackberry I doubt you can fire well
he's fine
so I work in space so amazing appendix
three soft limits find anal fisting
strike it out you are this no you're not
putting those in my butt don't call your
boy
what are bucks critics poster favors and
franchise I don't make love I've hard I
was going to romantic and then you just
go and distract me with your kinky green
it's not 50 shades of oh sorry Frances
fifty shades free King put me out of my
misery already you can rest now John
background on Hyde went to Princeton on
scholarship graduated summa [__] laude
worked for publishers in New York in
Chicago before I sent a bang-up job team
you found his LinkedIn pause that's
quintuple estupid because he worked for
you yeah yeah he worked for Christian
Grey you would know his resume right I
mean he didn't hire him but it would be
a huge things on file you would think
right good lord
you know what that you know what this
means it means that Christian Grey is
paying top dollar for really terrible
security they've convinced him that
they're great and they're the most
incompetent private security firm it's
true they a lot of it a lot of bad more
interested in that movie of these guys
who like come up with the ultimate scam
and there's a it's basically Super
Troopers except for like the fights
they're on screen yeah like they're
they're behind this needs kicking each
other in the balls riding crops
mmm did you lock the back door no so
many good movies to be made out of this
one but not this one not this one not
this one at all not these ones Wow
well let's see some deleted scenes what
a whole run this this is the one that we
cut because you had to have seen the
movie to appreciate it we assumed you
have insisted we haven't so now the
final chapter knives with all the sex
appeal of a studio comedy aimed at
senior citizens from what I hear this
book is quite stimulating looks sexier
but this grand finale has so much more
than sex toys and promotions to job she
already had
who's the new fiction editor you are
what was her last new fiction editor she
got the job she already there's a plot
remember Anna's old boss he must have
edited a lot of Tom Clancy novels
because he's a superspy now good that's
Jack watch him kidnap a character who
don't even remember but thanks to jerk
offs good and Haws will his plan to sow
the character they kidnapped because
these people are so miserable and
friendless and alone the closest
relative to Anna they could find the
kidnap was her stepsister in-law like a
friend of hers or like her mom or like
someone close to her they're like well
nobody likes this person not her
roommate no no that wasn't a roommate
was Christian's brothers my brother's
wife oh okay his roommates it's
Christian yeah I thought she was dating
Christian's brother no that I don't know
who any of these people
anna has no friends no none no me the
bike because Christian ensured that she
had no friends the only people who like
them are members around them are hired
or related yes so alright let's keep
going or hey but thanks to jerk-offs gun
and it will fall his plan to make
Christian pay for getting adopted that's
hi that's me
wait what exactly was his plan he got a
job at a publishing firm Christian
didn't Oh
as revenge the DRN on purpose was
getting fired for coming on or an
accident or did he mean to do that was
this plot always to get acquired by
Christians company get fired and then
get revenge on top of his revenge or
just to get revenge did they take a very
easy motivation to make it a hundred
times more complicated for no reason
yes yes they did yeah these are the
books to adapt right so yet to recap the
plan of this guy he is in the same
foster family as Christian gray he was
in the same adopted orphanage orphanage
he believed he's adopted by a different
family he believed he should have been
adopted by Christians family right he
moves on with his life he goes to
Princeton he goes to were looking for at
a book publishing company mm-hmm Rises
the ranks and two fiction editor two
fiction editor directly is not that hard
to get but well I go into Princeton and
all these other things still can't get
over the fact that he didn't get adopted
by a particular family family a
billionaires family right right but he
seemed parallel track it seems great Ivy
League school a great job seems to be
doing just fine but I guess still
harbors a lot of resentment
yes Christian Grey's adoptive family or
no at Christian Grey not as yes because
this is because he was not adopted by
ourselves then in walks Anastasia Steele
Eden walks Anastasia Steele you know she
is this before after Christian buys the
company though this is before is this is
where she works didn't you work at a
hardware store she did she's right how
did she get that job I guess maybe
Christian got it no no she starts there
as like an admin assistant yeah she's in
great and then he buys the company I
hope they're dating because she's like
that's weird and he's like yes it is and
they continue so yeah unrelated she gets
a job at this publishing house where
jack is the fiction editor yes and I
guess he sees this opportunity to could
pack a Christian Grey by getting himself
fired for assaulting her yep leaving him
destitute yep yeah leave iam destiny
which would be enough
motivation by the way if he were just
some guy that worked at a publishing
house and then he were fired from that
publishing house and replaced
that's enough motivation right there
however no no it's got to be 10 layers
deeper in ways that don't make sense
yeah the best part to me is that those
10 layers don't even show up until it's
all been resolved
yeah the classics happens they arrest
him and then like weeks later they're
hanging out in the kitchen and they look
at that photo with that thing where
they're like oh my god that's me
that's supposed to happen at like the
end of your second movie and you go whoa
and then you hit credits yeah I really
wish it would have just been so much
better if they made him like a
billionaire orphan you know who would
also you know like opposed to Christian
there are business rivals but he was
really into like clown sex or something
like that like he had a different thing
differently unacceptable
and clown shoes and and and I was like
who should I go if I don't know like
this guy's like there's so many ways we
could have improved on this movie yeah
or anyone really could have improved on
it yeah so it's not one of the all-time
not a great plans to get to assault the
girlfriend of your rival to get you
fired from the job - then yeah - then
orchestrate a circus created separate
wrench part where you kidnap his
stepsister and but then also tell them
that you're the kidnap I would have
brought to you flawlessly this is by the
legendary snow queen ice dragon yeah
this is the point in any other movie
adaptation we're in the process of
adapting it
the screenwriter that the studio hired
would have said you know this doesn't
quite make sense maybe we should rework
this but yell James said make a little
more direct that should be my husband
and you're not changing a word yeah and
here we are yeah that's mr. snow queen
ice dragon to you well there you go guys
put a button on it zip it up forever
slap it and send it off down its way
we're done with the Fifty Shades trilogy
in the Red Room lock it in the Red Room
put that Red Room on a boat and sink
to the bottom of the ocean I hope it's
been as interesting for you as it has
for us we've we've certainly enjoyed
some of it mostly not huh but we'll be
back next week for a much more enjoyable
interesting film yes yes something that
you know is how can I tease this yeah
it's a collective work yourself out of
the box here
well it's something that people have
been asking for forever
yes forever for yeah yeah forever yeah
and you'll get it next week
mm-hmm so we'll see you then thank you
sticking around
[Music]
you